disney gets down to business with a live
action remake of their animated mulan
but is it as powerful pleasurable and
indestructible as the original
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and today
i'm explaining the 14
biggest differences between the new
movie and the 1998 classic
some spoilers ahead so take care if
you've not seen it yet
he may be a fan favorite but that didn't
save the much loved
mooshu from being cut from the new film
dishonor this honor on your whole family
brilliantly voiced by eddie murphy the
travel-sized dragon with a
larger-than-life personality brought a
wealth of memorable moments and
hilarious comic relief to the animated
movie
i am the powerful the pleasurable
the indestructible however his comedic
tone didn't fit the style of the
live-action film which leans more
towards
epic martial arts war movie and
crucially while many western disney fans
love mushu
according to producer jason reed his
silly shenanigans didn't play well to
audiences in china where dragons are
important symbols of power strength and
good fortune
in contrast to western mythology where
they've often been seen as dangerous and
aggressive creatures to be defeated
the new mulan does have a mythological
sidekick of sorts though this
time her guardian is a phoenix a silent
character that guides her on her journey
to duty honor and being true to herself
in chinese tradition the phoenix is
often regarded as a symbol of female
power and together with the dragon the
pair of mythological creatures sit on
either side of the emperor
there are some beautiful shots of the
phoenix appearing at crucial moments in
mulan's story
and although it is sad to lose the
iconic character of mushu his
replacement with the phoenix does better
suit this more serious
version of the tale the remake
introduces several brand new characters
my favorite of these is a sorceress
played by gong lee who's an ally of the
movie's main villain bori khan
she's a powerful and intriguing figure
and the way she shapeshifts into
birds creates some truly arresting
visuals and is also a hat tip to villain
chanu's falcon in the original movie
of course she's much more crucial to the
plot than the 1998 film's bird of prey
with her shape-shifting and magical
ability to take over another human body
proving integral to the villain's
strategy and her character also adds an
interesting parallel with mulan
balancing the protagonist's story as she
knows what it feels like to be
ostracized for being different and
powerful
and her arc enhances the themes of
identity and belonging so crucial to the
film
when it came to mulan's lucky sidekick
qrikey who communicates via chirps
what you mean a loser rather than
cutting him out of the new film entirely
disney took a different
approach keeping his spirits alive by
adding a brand new human character who's
appropriately called cricket
cricket is a fellow army recruit whose
mother says he's a good luck charm
and just like the animated bug
unwittingly got mulan into trouble the
new cricket also accidentally causes a
minor ruckus at the garrison as the new
recruits line up
and like his animated insect counterpart
this cricket also helped mulan out at
some key moments
he's a really sweet new character who
adds some nice comedic touches to the
film
which makes the movies fake out at the
end all the more unbearable
like mushu one character that fans may
find themselves missing is army captain
and love interest lee shang
for the live live-action version his
character has been split in two
with donnie yen playing commander tongue
mulan superior
mentor and actor yosan and taking on the
role of hong koi
a trainee soldier who after a rocky
start sees that there's something
different about mulan compared to the
others and ends up a close ally
according to the film's producer jason
reed the filmmakers felt it was
inappropriate for mulan's commanding
officer to be her love interest in the
remake
so they removed the power differential
by making hong hwa her equal in the army
and similar to the animation there are
some hints at something more between
them
what if she doesn't like me she will
i mean i think she will you know you
never know with women
interestingly the film's hair and makeup
designer has said they went for a young
clean-shaven look that was both feminine
and masculine for hongwei so that mulan
would fit in better when she joins up
and pretends to be male and also because
his character has a fragility to him
when reed was asked whether his
character would be regarded as a
potential lgbtq icon in the way that lee
shang is he said it will play in the
same way as it does in the animated film
as they use that as their model
given the way the live action movie ends
though it feels like the romantic
connection between the two is downplayed
compared to the original
would you like to stay for dinner would
you like to stay forever
dinner would be great the new film does
stick to the main story beats of the
1998 one
but unlike some other disney live-action
adaptations it isn't a shot-for-shot
remake so expect some well-known scenes
to get the chop
for example the animation's iconic scene
of mulan slicing off her long locks to
disguise herself as a soldier
doesn't make it into the live-action
movie for many western audiences cutting
her hair
short was an empowering moment
symbolizing her leaving behind her old
life and its rigid gender-based
expectations
however that moment rang false to
audiences in china as in their culture
male warriors wore their hair long so
the new film takes the animated scene
and gives it a twist
creating its own new empowering moment
for our heroine when she decides to let
her hair loose and willingly reveal her
true identity
this moment comes just after mulan's
one-to-one encounter with the sorceress
who accuses her of hiding who she really
is
your deceit weakens you it poisons your
chi
seeing her tresses flow free as she
fights fiercely on the battlefield as a
moving moment
because mulan has made her own choice to
unmask herself to the world
by contrast in the animation she's
forced out of her male disguise and
unintentionally reveals herself as a
woman
after being injured in battle in the new
version mulan gets to take back her
power
embrace her full identity and make her
own decision as to when it's time to
reveal who she really is
another memorable moment in the animated
movie comes after lee shang tells our
heroine she's not good enough to be a
soldier and orders her to go home
dejected she begins to leave but then
decides to retrieve the arrow from the
pole that everyone has so far
failed to climb using her smarts she
repurposes the heavy weights to help her
scale the pole and reach the arrow
in the live action the poll is gone but
the incredibly difficult task this time
is to walk all the way up an enormous
mountain carrying heavy pails of water
the interesting difference between the
two movies is that in the animation it's
more mulan's ingenuity and determination
that help her succeed in this seemingly
impossible task
whereas in the live action it's her chi
that powers her up the mountain summit
overall the new movie emphasizes the
power of mulan's chi
is making her special which isn't to say
that this mulan isn't smart but it is a
notable difference between the two films
the animations big bad the hun army and
their leader shanyu
have been replaced by bori khan and his
roaring fighters from the north
khan's described by director nikki
carrow as somebody who it looks like
everybody has tried to kill but nobody
has succeeded
and he's played by jason scott lee who
starred in disney live-action
adaptations before
having brought mowgli to life in the
1994 version of the jungle book
another new character introduced in the
latest version is mulan's younger sister
the filmmakers felt it added a broader
emotional context and more motivation
for our heroine especially at the end of
the film
on top of that the differences between
the two sisters helped to highlight just
how different mulan is to other young
women
but adding a new relative to the story
meant the wisecracking grandmother from
the animation who spit in her bean curd
got the boot as they wanted to keep the
focus on woodland's parents
and sister instead in a change from the
animated movie where mulan is already a
young woman at the start
the remake opens with her as a child
this new way of introducing her gives us
some backstory for her character
demonstrating her athleticism and
agility and her strong connection to
achieve from an early age
mulan's striking difference to the other
children in the village and the way the
rest of her neighbors view her
gives us an insight into how society
treats women who don't fit its norms and
the problems it creates for her parents
it is mulan i worry about they'll call
her
witch as producer reed says she has all
these great qualities but she doesn't do
things the way a young girl supposed to
and it isn't until she's dressed as a
boy that people encourage those things
in her
this new opening to the story brings
some comedy to the film as well and also
includes a cool call back to the scene
in the original movie where mulan's dog
little brother helps her with their
chores looking after the chickens
this time though it's a young mulan
herself who energetically chases around
with the chickens and races through the
temple where a pile of fruit takes a
tumble
rather than in the animation where it's
her father's teacup that hits the floor
that fun little sequence does mean
there's no canine character this time
but that's
understandable as this really isn't the
type of disney film where animals
performing household tasks fits in
as for mulan's horse he's got very
similar colouring to her animated horse
khan but given the more realistic feel
of this film don't expect the same
expressive body language or facial
expressions
i'm working on it owen his name in the
new movie is actually black wind because
calling him
khan would be very confusing given the
main villain is named bori khan
in a bold move the creative team behind
mulan chose to move away from the
musical genre in complete contrast to
many other recent disney remakes such as
beauty and the beast aladdin and the
lion king
although the new film does have
fantastical elements it leans more
heavily into epic war territory so the
filmmakers wanted to keep the world
more grounded and realistic and they
felt that mulan bursting into song to
reflect on her situation or the imperial
soldiers busting out a tune while
getting down to business during a
training montage wouldn't set the right
tone
while we don't get any show-stopping
musical numbers we do get some
instrumental tributes to the classic
songs and the movie score and also in
its dialogue
and if you want to know where they all
appear the details are in my mulan
easter eggs and things you missed video
tap here to watch that or follow the
link in the video description
i'll add it here as soon as it's ready
on top of that during the end credits we
hear
two new versions of reflections one by
christina aguilera who also performed
the song for the animation
and one in mandarin by mulan star yifei
plus
aguilera also performs a brand new song
loyal brave and
true written specially for the remake
and inspired by the virtues engraved on
mulan's sword
so what do you think about the new mulan
movie and how do you feel about the
changes
leave your thoughts in the comments
below if you enjoyed this then do leave
a thumbs up it really helps and i hugely
appreciate it
tap left for my next mulan video or tap
right for something else you're sure to
like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippie kaio movie lovers
you